I did
[Music]
welcome everybody to LED live it's good
to have you here with us today I just
want to introduce the new face around
the table this is denique welcome Denise
what's up everybody a little bit of LED
history danique actually used to work
with us when we were in Scotty's
basement that's right and a long time
ago
that time we didn't have a show like we
have now so you may have seen her on
videos in the past and if you think she
looks familiar that way
yeah I just took a little that's true
replacement Gods too she's she's gotten
older matured and she's actually getting
ready to get married that's right so
that's awesome yeah it's exciting well
prior to the show we were actually
talking about all kinds of things like
kindy's Mobile plan yeah
you know thread versus uh Twitter and
then that led into who's gonna win the
cage fight between musk and Zuckerberg
we're not going to talk about that today
actually
um we're we're not all dressed in pink
to talk about Barbie but we will be
talking about Barbie so what do you have
about Barbie okay so have you guys seen
anything in the news about Barbie and
how it's blowing up I've seen the
trailers
it's not in my algorithm at all yeah it
started appearing in my algorithm
because I had to do some research but um
Barbie
um the movie is coming out end of this
month recruiting we're recording in July
and
um I mean apparently there's like Barbie
cafes that people are popping up and and
news anchors are dressed up in pink
visiting these places I've been noticing
just people on Facebook wearing all pink
together at parties and stuff I'm like
yeah I didn't think it was going to be
that big yeah so I mean it's it's kind
of crazy when you think about a Barbie
movie right being so big
um but let's just watch the trailer real
quick and see what is going on with this
movie and um you know I think we all
know this is going to be same old same
old storyline and we'll kind of look at
what's wrong with it
foreign
[Music]
can I come to your house tonight sure
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
it is the best day ever so is yesterday
and so is tomorrow and every day from
now until forever
do you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks
okay I cut this trailer up in different
segments because I want to look at
different pieces but
first things what what's what stands out
everything's perfect yep why are the
tough questions always a bird buzz kill
like why can't it just be cool it's part
of life deep conversation
yeah before we get there though I I have
a question it's not tough but did you
play with Barbies when you were little
I didn't I was a bit of a tomboy at the
time okay I hated skirts and pink
I actually hated pink and any dresses I
so Barbies I played with like the baby
dolls the big babies yeah same I can
relate to that my mom was really
intentional about not getting that for
like you know my growth and development
and all of that she was also looking for
diversity which Barbie didn't have so I
she got me the
American Girl American Girl dolls yeah
but not the dolls too expensive the
books okay I read the books but I grew
up on like stuffed animals and like
um
Sesame Street characters oh that was my
childhood monsters yeah okay did you
play with me
I was hoping I hoping it wouldn't come
this way but uh I did
[Music]
yeah
you're an honest man yeah
I mean to be completely honest then I
thought she was pretty
and that's why I like playing with her
did you go full on like dollhouse no no
no no okay I did ask I was there was a
why are we even going here
my parents friend babysat me one time
and I wanted a Barbie doll and she
bought it for me my parents like why'd
you buy her my son of Barbie doll he
wanted it and I honestly just thought
she looked pretty well that would be
seen as very Progressive nowadays yeah
right yeah and look at me now I I didn't
chop anything off I'm still the same you
know sometimes it just
one thing I noticed they're all wearing
white at this party
um there the island is the shape of a
heart we know Heaven is a place of love
and like he said everything's perfect
every day is perfect this symbol right
here is actually
this looks a little similar to a pagan
symbol right here
which one like this this right here this
like half I don't know which one it was
it's uh the wheel the wheel like the
wheel of something all the holidays and
stuff the saw wins yeah I think so yeah
just throwing it out I don't know what
they did it on purpose it's just
interesting
Barbie land okay and it seems very
exclusive because outside like look at
the terrain outside of the heart dry oh
even the water so this is like the
perfect world right everything is
perfect they're having a good time
nobody thinks about death nobody thinks
about death except now Barbie's like do
you guys ever think about dying and
everybody's like oh my gosh well it's so
perfect she even floats off of her house
even when she takes her perfect high
heel feet off you know shoes off her
feet are still like that yeah which a
lot of women would consider that like
perfect I guess so so the reason why
they did that is because the Barbie
apparently now they changed it but you
know the Barbie doll was always the
focus was up so they recreated that um
but later on we'll see a segment where
they have an issue with her feet well
one one good thing we'll throw out there
speaking of diversity Barbie has gotten
really diverse that's true have you seen
that I've seen wheelchair Barbie I've
seen different routes
I mean that's a long question they have
short wide all all I mean I've been down
the aisle in Walmart and I'm like wow
yeah it's actually impressive yeah
okay let's look at the next uh clip so
this is an interview that they did we'll
go back to the trailer after this
um just listen to what they say this is
the cast of the Barbie so this uh chick
on the right
um ah what's her name again Australian
actress
Margot Robbie she plays the main Barbie
and the other uh the two in the left
here also play Barbie and this girl with
a black suit she is they're all named
Barbie they're all different Barbies
like with different like the Multiverse
basically and the trick on in the black
suit on the right she is a uh a human
because she goes to the real world
eventually so let's watch this you know
Barbie line is perfect so it's really
just maintaining the order of perfection
um the compliments are absolutely
essential we dance parties dance parties
lots of words yeah every 90 minutes I
love your Barbie Friends words of
affirmation constantly
um everything was you know universally
free universally free education
Healthcare everything signed into laws
so quick clip just to show you it's not
just us saying it's perfect they say it
themselves it's a perfect world it's
supposed to be that way even in that
trailer they're like every day is
perfect yeah and we just did a Show
recently showing movie after movie there
was a fighting against Perfection it was
uh Tron and the Matrix and Guardians of
the Galaxy there's so many movies where
it's like Perfection is looked at as
something boring or just bad in general
yeah I mean everything she described who
wouldn't want to live in a world where
you know everything is like constant
affirmation Joy all this stuff yeah
ugly dolls is another one yeah yeah
same story every single time they and it
makes you think like why would they want
to share the same story every time about
this perfect world and we'll see later
on where oh but the perfect world is bad
you need to go live your life a little
bit right what's interesting is how we
don't pick up on it yeah I mean I I was
a Christian for eight years before the
blinders fell off and I was even
you know when people said Harry Potter
was pushing Witchcraft and stuff I
couldn't even see that it's like what
kind of spell is this thing casting on
people that we can watch the same story
over and over and over and just not even
pick up on it it's pretty weird
yeah we all identify with those things
psychologically you know it's like we
inherently know
the Bible says that God has put eternity
in our heart Ecclesiastes so we know
that things aren't the way they should
be really and we know it's a messed up
world the messed up World's the one we
can identify with and so it's the one we
feel most comfortable in at the time so
the idea of a perfect world is you know
in some ways becomes a little unsettling
to people how do you how do you live in
that world what's what's that like you
know it's
it's unknown this is this is where they
show you the sets this little behind the
scenes clip the kitchen's great so we
have a mixture of you know things that
are physically there but then also decal
because again playing into the world of
toys and and how it would look if it was
a Mattel product
um our kitchen being a great example of
that so on the back here you have just a
decal uh you know so it is intentionally
2D and it's that thing where we want
things to be obviously artificial but
still very satisfying
come and see the phone
there is no water in Barbie land there's
no water or fire there are no elements
it's actually funny to see how many
people avoid walking everyone walks
around the pool
even though it's fake it's really
beautiful which is kind of like
everything in Barbie land
even though it's fake it's really
beautiful
beautiful like like who wants to live in
like interesting uh thought that
Perfection is an illusion yeah that it's
not real not attainable also going back
to the thing of like the water being
different so I guess that ocean peace in
the heart was fake
yeah seeing as crystal clear water is
real yeah so that so to so to me this is
again
we we know working in this industry you
never do anything just because right
like you no nothing is an accident and I
watched some
um behind the scenes with the uh
director as well it's a female she she
talks about the things that she puts in
there on purpose she thinks about
everything is this a Tesla it's like a
self-driving car yeah right yeah no that
is interesting that you know when we say
something we point something out the
comeback is always you guys are looking
way too deep it's not that deep it's
just you know mindless entertainment
just you know just watch it enjoy it but
then
if if they're not coming at the angle
that we are you can look up stuff uh
movies like The Matrix and and you'll
find out that people say this movie
changed my life they say it's so deep I
mean how they think about all that stuff
and it just blew my mind but then when
we do the very same thing point out just
how really deep it is no we're looking
way too deep yeah it's just because
the angle we're coming at it is
there's something in here that you
shouldn't be entertaining your mind with
yeah there should be some kind of change
that comes with this
yeah
so a very plastic World very perfect
world let's continue with the trailer
some things have been happening that
might be related
cold shower falling off my roof
And my heels
are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so here comes the obvious storyline
the perfect rule is no longer perfect
flat feet everything is falling apart
cold showers I think she even I even
read that all of a sudden she's having a
cellulite don't quote me on this I don't
know no that's for sure I just read it
somewhere it says cellulite says flat
feet she has cold showers she falls off
the roof like oh my gosh what is
happening I'm wondering what is what is
that a result of did it start just like
out of the blue or is it when she
started questioning then all of these
things started happening to her as a
um
penalty or something like that because
then even that's a bad
mentality or thought to have especially
when you think about attributing it to
God like we can't question anything we
can't God says come let us reason
together he entertains questions he he
wants to converse with us and so we
should never be afraid to question
things or approach God especially since
he has provided us a whole book The
Bible that has all the answers amen yeah
but is this subtle philosophies that are
in these movies that
slip into your subconscious and you
start believing it and then down the
road you find yourself way like in a
position you never thought you'd be in
and it all starts from these subtleties
from a gnostic point of view I mean Adam
and Eve were in this perfect world
Lucifer said you can eat this fruit of
knowledge knowledge of Good and Evil and
it wasn't a bad thing when they ate it
oh they they had all the knowledge so I
mean if this is that is a perfect world
she's questioning things and and so far
it looks like it's bad like oh no my
feet are flat and there's cold showers
and I fell but I have a feeling that
they're gonna find out this isn't that
bad yep yeah do you want to go a little
into what narcissism is for those that
don't know yeah it's just the you know
basically an inversion of the Bible it's
the belief it's elusive arianism it's
Lucifer a luciferian idea that
you have the whole story of what the
Bible says except Lucifer wasn't evil he
wasn't deceiving Adam and Eve he was
actually trying to open their eyes
because God is some tyrannical villain
that's keeping them in this perfect
world when there's a whole world outside
there that he was keeping them from he
was keeping them from knowledge yeah
that's what that's what the the
accusation of the enemy was is that God
is he doesn't want you to be smart he
doesn't want you to know the truth but
if you eat this fruit that he's trying
to keep you from then you'll know the
truth and you'll be enlightened and
evolved and all these things and it came
from
Christians who I guess you could say
kind of strayed from the faith and have
different different ideas offshoot
offshoot yeah who had this like Gnostic
ideas and it's still happening today
yeah somebody who's agnostic means that
they don't have knowledge that just
means no knowledge but the gnostics they
had the knowledge that's what they
believed so yeah
is looking at the plot line on
this website I think it's Looper yeah
Looper
so when you're kind of reading through
and you get to the last part where it
says most alarmingly of all Barbie is
suddenly haunted by thoughts of death
hoping to find answers to Life's biggest
questions she decides to venture out
into the real world with a stowaway Ken
tagging along unfortunately this is
frowned upon by the executives
Mattel the company that makes Barbie
yeah the creators yeah by the creators
and it reminded me of the like it
reminded me of The Lego Movie very much
yeah like there's the creator of the
Lego Universe in The Lego Movie who is
very much portrayed as God
um and if anyone hasn't seen that video
we did on it it's a couple years ago
just look up little s Studios Lego Movie
you'll find it
um but this is the same setup and you'll
see it apart toward the end of the
trailer you'll see Mattel looks gray and
dull and it's just men in suits humans
only have one ending
[Music]
you know like God is gray and dull and
just like
the audience sympathizes with Barbie
during this stage in the same way that
gnostics sympathize with Lucifer yeah he
was just seeking truth and look look
what's happening to him because of you
know his Pursuit for truth you know it's
also kind of interesting to me
um The Lego Movie do you remember who
one of the main actors was in that
um Chris Pratt whoever whoever plays the
it's like the same character same
character same setup
and you think like oh but these actors
they don't know they do know they do
came up with this idea like
let's make a movie about Barbie but in
the world it's like
Perfection she doesn't want Perfection
yeah like how can they just keep coming
with the same plot are they do they say
hey we have this plot and we need a new
package to put it in like what can what
what other what other package can we put
this we don't like perfection in or is
it just literally like hey it'd be cool
to make a Barbie movie what was the
story be about I don't know maybe
Perfection sucks like how do they I
don't understand how it happens every
time Margot Robbie apparently approached
the director but director also wrote the
script
but it's it's interesting because
um because there's so much information
out there if you do some research about
actors that channel Spirits actors that
uh if you have you guys ever read
um what's the French Canadian guy's name
who was a Satanist uh Roger Morneau he
wrote a book
a trip into this contributed to
Supernatural
and he he was a Satanist who uh was I
guess you could say had access to some
private meetings and he was told like
Satan had a meeting
um with with you know I guess his either
his demons or like his actual high up
satanists and he was talking about this
is exactly what we're going to do we're
going to use media
to to deceive the world this is one of
the meaning the other one was Evolution
uh there's a few things aliens um
and so so yeah like there see there are
these celebrities if you watch uh
um Walter White uh Vitus v e i t h if
you watch his series total Onslaught
which again you can watch for free on
YouTube
um he he has so much evidence
for these celebrities and presidents and
everybody that are part of secret
societies he literally has documents
stating this he's it's not a a lie or
just a joke like this is actually
happening and if you think about it
Jesus was tempted by Satan before he
went to the Wilderness and one of the
things Satan offered him is all of the
world
and he said no
wouldn't he offer that to every single
other person and they say yes
so yeah there's people literally live
like Gods you think about it I mean
they're just everywhere they go
everything's free even though they got
more money than they can spend they're
worshiped yeah yeah literally called
Idols yeah but yeah Roger Moore know he
also talked about a room full of
typewriters that were typing themselves
and stuff so you know these these
writers they say I got this from a dream
you know our Avatar and James Cameron he
openly admits that these his scripts
came from a dream as well as many other
authors like uh JK Rowling she saw Harry
Potter on the train like like wrote it
on a napkin and now it's like the third
best-selling next to the Bible or
something yeah yeah well we believe
Hollywood is like Satan's Bible so to
speak because all of these themes are in
direct conflict with the true word of
God the Holy Bible and so the fact that
the biblical writers were inspired by
the Holy Spirit they were inspired by
God in the same way a lot of these movie
writers directors producers are inspired
by and they say it this is not just me
we have so many interviews of them
saying I was inspired by this you know
odd looking being or my spirit guide or
what have you we have episodes about
that people coming out of the new age
talking about their spirit guide and how
they were leading them into lies instead
of the truth and so who was author of
Lies the devil and so the devil is
influencing these things and he has his
ideas his stories that he's pushing and
he's going to keep doing that even
though it's packaged differently and so
him being the counterfeit to God him
using God's Playbook and twisting it the
same way that God imparts his
inspiration unto us Satan is doing the
same thing that's why you see duplicates
over and over and over all over
Hollywood let me see I think there's
another clip that's similar to this one
right after
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
and go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
a choice is now
the first one the high heel you have to
want to know okay do it again
can I do you for
I see you about my feet
they're um
flap
yeah never seen that before you see what
what do I have to do you think you would
go
to the real world you can go back to
your regular life and forget any of this
ever happened or you can know the truth
about the universe
the first one the high heel
we'll do a redo
still wanna know
you're supposed to want to know I want
to point out the one who's offering the
truth is just like chaos you know yeah
messy hair
like drawings on her face and
this is Satan the Lawless one like
that's the one that wants to offer you
the truth you know but the ones that you
said are the executives they're the ones
that are hiding everything from you
that's true very colorful and you see
that that it's still colorful but it's
really messy like you said the house is
messy everything is messy and then
something specific is uh she was
offering Birkenstocks Birkenstocks are
known to provide arch support for people
with flat feet
and so she's like I want to wear the
heels I want to wear what I've known but
known to wear it's like no embrace your
situation with your feet the
imperfection and run with it that's what
they're saying yeah
so very interesting so we're identifying
the the character with the mess here and
all of that
um as
the villain whereas in the context of
the movie is that the person who's
running the whole I guess I would look
at that character as like the in
gnosticism like this is the Sophia yeah
you know the one that's offering the
truth the one that's offering you know
is the gnostics look at it like the
serpent offering the knowledge like
don't you want the knowledge of
Lucy of all things and then Truman shows
a woman named something like Sophia or
something it's always this woman that's
trying to bring the truth I can't
remember some of the other examples uh
smallfoot same thing this the stone
Keeper's daughter was the one let's look
at another one
yep so listen to these lyrics and I'll
point out the lyrics right after uh
again they do everything on purpose you
don't just pick a random song to play
for this scene you write it into the
script it's not that annoying Barbie
song no no no no no
which by the way is very R-rated if you
actually listen to the Barbie song
lyrics but this is different
closer I am
[Music]
[Applause]
coming with you okay okay let's jump
into the lyrics
the song that they're singing is Closer
To Fine by the Indigo Girls and listen
to what it says I'm trying to tell you
something about my life maybe give me
Insight between black and white and the
best thing you ever done for me is to
help me take my life less seriously it's
only life after all yeah now this line
right here well Darkness has a hunger
that is insatiable and lightness has a
call that's hard to hear and I wrap my
fear around me like a blanket I sell my
ship of safety till I sank it I'm
crawling on your Shores and I went to
the doctor I went to the mountains I
looked to the children I drank from the
fountains there's more than one answer
to these questions point to me in a
crooked line and the less I seek my
source for some definitive the less I
seek my source closer I am to fine isn't
that super Gnostic too it's pretty
messed up right yeah so yeah good I have
a hunger for Darkness you know sin light
is hard to understand I don't even want
to hear it and that's what the Bible
talks about the darkness hates the light
and then we're supposed to walk the
straight and narrow that few will go
into and she's like look the truth is
showing me this crooked line and and uh
that's the that's the closer I'm getting
to fine that's the closer I'm getting to
truth is following this crooked line
that has more than one answer and the
less I seek my
true I would say is the Bible
the close I am to find
and played and she's
leaving Barbie land the perfect world
and she's going to the real world yeah
so wow
wow that was a good uh good thing you
looked that up I don't have you even
thought
I didn't even like pay attention to what
the song was saying and she was singing
I was more noticing that she was singing
Out Of Tune and stuff because I'm sure
that's part of it you know she's her
feet are flat now and she can't she's
out too and all that yeah
I think one more thing and that's it no
I mean I think I think it's like it's
like when I read the script I was like I
knew I've I actually went to college
with Greta you guys so oh yeah I know
that she's like like I knew that even
before
anyways can we do comedy shows with
gretiger I did actually which is so full
circle I actually did
um so I knew like how brilliant she was
and when I heard she was doing the
Barbie movie I was like what is this
gonna be and but I knew it was going to
be something and then I read it and I
was like
about sort of about how like gender
roles deny people half their humanity
and how like
we need to just like be ourselves and
it's like a very
powerful message and so like
I spot a Ken it's just like everyone's
everyone's themselves you know yeah
you know everything about that in the
car
so she's one of the hosts of SNL right
or what used to be I don't know but she
played that chaotic looking Barbie okay
so they're talking about gender roles
right and how generals deny your what
Identity or something it's not the whole
you you're only half of you because I
mean it's crazy you don't have to teach
a little girl to want to play with a a
baby doll like I went when I was in
Bolivia I talked to these people they
say we never gave our daughter baby
dolls it just wasn't something we did
and yet she would pick up a squash and
put a little blanket over and be
cradling a squash it's a natural
instinct a motherly Instinct in a woman
whereas a boy he wants to go over there
and crash cars and yeah you know Hammer
nails and stuff it's just ingrained in
us it's not like some social construct
that we're trying to at some point in
time they said no this section you only
bear babies and take care of them and
you you do hard work and but think about
it you know when we were doing the
research on The Matrix right
and you look at where the Wachowski
Brothers went like what were they really
trying to get at with the whole Matrix
film no they said it was all about trans
exactly so being very similar in its
approach and style and all that would we
expect anything right different no no
you wouldn't and and to be honest it's
not
um it's the same kind of thinking it's
the same Gnostic New Age thinking and
the reason I say that is because they
teach that the physical world is is more
or less like a prison right the physical
world is what you have to get past what
you really need to get to is the
spiritual world that's who you really
are that's where you're really free and
so this material body is just you know
it's just
it's not that important yeah
so Harry Neff is a trans actor
um and so uh he is a male who
transitioned to a female and he is one
of the Barbies
um and here's a statement on them Us in
an interview promoting the much
anticipated sure to be Blockbuster film
Barbie Harry Neff who plays one of the
many iterations of Barbie in the film
shared the very interesting and very
very gay background she made up for her
character in an interview with Vogue
Neff said that she believes that rather
than a little girl her Barbie who is
canonically a doctor is owned by a doll
collector who is a gay man in his 50s
who lives in a rent controlled apartment
in West Village Nev's super gay
backstory was influenced by the care
characters over the top fashiony crazy
costumes this is him her quoting I was
like this is no child's doll she said I
feel like every week he has his two or
three friends over maybe he's a little
lonely and you know shows them my new
outfit and I just kind of stay in my box
so
um yeah interesting stuff that they have
to put in a trans person in in the
Barbie movie and make them a Barbie
um this is not really a kids movie it's
more for adults but still it's the same
agenda I do want to emphasize
um just so the viewers know we don't we
don't hate gay people we don't hate
trans people I have a friend who came
out as such
um
but you know we do believe that what the
word of God says as much as we respect
anyone and you respect them as people we
do
um you don't agree with the agenda
that's being pushed in in Hollywood the
truth will make you free and the truth
is that God made you the way he made you
and that's who you really are it's
ironic to me I saw a video of a a bunch
of trans people
attacking this pastor guy who was just
out there reading his Bible and they
were just getting louder and louder and
louder and surrounded him and and they
were saying and they were singing born
this way and I'm like how ironic to say
born this way when you're literally
mutilating your body to be something
else that you were not born as just
really ironic if you define who you are
then you kind of supersede the Creator
oh right exactly
um do you know that it's actually banned
in Vietnam I did why do you think that
it is
is it just Vietnam or is it China I mean
there's a little bit of spillover but
why why would you say that it may not be
for the reason that you think no
uh they're very particular as to what
kind of messages go out into their
societies wow whether it be religion or
political
you're definitely right it's
geographical this time so
listen to this so when you think oh like
okay it's just a movie it's just
entertainment there's nothing in there
right
but movies are made and they make
statements
so the reason for the band this is
according to
um collider okay is due to a scene in
which a map
now think how many scenes have Maps like
how detailed do you have to like watch
this thing to see this
but they think it's important important
enough to ban it in the whole country
depicting the dashed the nine dashed
line is featured do you know what that
is the nine dashed line is a U-shaped
line that is used to illustrate the
territory in a South China Sea which
both China and Vietnam claim as their
own
the nine dashed line is used in Chinese
maps to designate the country's claim
over 90 percent of the Sea and the line
affects more than just Vietnam though
the Philippines Indonesia
Bruni Malaysia and Taiwan have long been
in a border debate over the sea and are
all affected by China's claim on it
so you'd think that would have just
Photoshopped it out or whatever but that
is really interesting according to
Vietnam's Department of Cinema
the guy who's ahead of that said we do
not Grant license for the American movie
Barbie to release in Vietnam because it
contains the offending image of the
nine-dash line they're probably even
more particular about American movies
specifically you know what I mean like
fine-tooth comb sure but I mean yeah
that's interesting political statement
right and it was a map that was like a
prop on set it wasn't like just in a
background somewhere like Barbie was
standing right in front of it it's in
the trailer and it'll be interesting to
take a poll like have a bunch of people
watch the film and ask them hey did you
did you pick up on that map can you tell
me when that happened
but they are
really saying it doesn't matter whether
you pick up it on it or not the
subconscious will pick up on it and you
know a theory will develop in your mind
and that could affect us now or in the
future who knows so let's just put a
stop to it now a movie won't affect you
and even
films believe it matters they're very
particular and those watching it and I
was like oh it's just a movie it's like
you buy a car oh it's just a car I'll
put water in the tank who cares like
whatever it's like no this is how the
manufacturer made it very specific and
they're giving you and even in this
interviews they're telling us exactly
what their intentions were in the manual
of a car they tell you what the
intentions were of the car so it's like
who who are we as the users to to just
toss it aside like it's nothing like
that information isn't important
yesterday I had a Facebook memory pop-up
and it was a post of mine talking about
how Dukes of Hazzard got banned Dukes of
Hazzard got taken off of Netflix I guess
it was because of its Confederate flag
on the car and it's like a main part of
the show you can't like just well we'll
get rid of this episode and Photoshop
that out I mean it's like all the time
but literally just you know some stripes
and stars in a certain order that's
offensive enough to pull the show
completely down
but movies don't affect us I don't have
an influence on the society or the world
you know you can't have it both ways and
the car was called the General Lee yeah
I I watched Scott Ritz a mess media on
the brain series a while ago or listen
to it
um and he talks about directors that
will openly say yeah like I'll flip a
little more with them flip a little
my view of the world is at them they're
saying it yeah
they're not they're not hiding it yeah
and that's really all they can do like
each one of us have our own perspectives
our opinions and we share our thoughts
what it is what God is calling us to do
is to be particular about
um or be Discerning as to who we listen
to who we engage with how much time you
spend listening to a certain thought or
Theory that's that's really it so to a
degree although I do believe that there
is demonic influence in some cases
to a degree it's like how can you fault
someone for just putting out their world
view okay cool but it's us as a church
that needs to be more particular about
what we allow in which is why we don't
agree that this should be outlawed you
shouldn't be allowed to do this we don't
believe in that we believe in boycott
over censorship you know everybody
should be able to have the right to put
their opinions out there but I think
there's a a lot of bias and censorship
like if Christians want to make this
awesome movie is universal going to put
it out probably not you know well
um okay so Barbie movie there's
definitely things in there yeah that are
either political or religious ideologies
or philosophical ideologies final
thoughts
don't go see it don't go see it okay you
know spend time with your family you
read your Bible there you go they do
such a good job at making it a likable
movie you know like they they really for
one kids are gonna like it it's Barbie
adults are gonna like it because it's
Nostalgia yeah and it's and they said
whether you like Barbie or hate Barbie
you're gonna love the movie because we
take Jabs at Barbie and if you like
Barbie then it's gonna look you know it
glamorizes her but at the same time
mocks her and stuff so they really it's
gonna cast a big net and it's gonna a
lot of people like this said it's it's
sure to be a blockbuster I guarantee
this is going to be like one of those
cult classics from 2023 you remember
that Barbie movie so funny and uh yeah
it'll be another Zoolander or whatever
but
yeah so I guess it comes out in a couple
weeks July 21. yeah so you were warned
that's right
all right candy any other thoughts from
you
all right well this has been another
episode of LED live thank you for
joining us keep in mind we have uh merch
we have shirts you can get them on
lightwear dot shop uh don't forget that
we're also on patreon we really
appreciate your support and your help in
making these kinds of Productions so you
can donate there and see some perks also
same perks same everything's available
on our website and actually if you
donate on our website it does actually
help us a lot because we get better
rates through credit card companies and
you can donate through your bank that
way too so thank you guys for your
support thank you for helping thank you
for watching and we will see you next
time on LED live
hey subscribe to Leola Studios
videos
if you want to learn Spanish a great way
we'll be watching our videos for
practice
[Music]